vitamin d affects a lot more than just
your immune system
and everything that vitamin d affects if
you compare
the symptoms of vitamin d deficiency
with the symptoms of severe covet 19
they match up almost perfectly
so for instance
just getting cover 19 in the first place
vitamin d strengthens the epithelial
junctions the tight junctions the gap
junctions the junctions between cells so
you're less likely to have an invader
such as the stars the stars co2 virus
even enter the system
if you have vitamin d levels high your
your basically your your walls
surrounding your city will be
strengthened by having good vitamin d
and so a lot of people are not ever
going to even test positive if they've
got a good vitamin d level then your
t-cell immunity is strengthened and
controlled so you're more likely to have
an appropriate reaction
to the invader rather than having an
overreaction where you you know burn all
your powder too quickly and then don't
have anything left or you do
catastrophic damage to yourself because
you're just shooting wildly um
so vitamin d helps with the adaptive
immunity as well as the innate immunity
and then it also controls um
some complicated things that we don't
need to go into like the renin
angiotensin system
and uh so there are other
more complex
systems within the body that go out of
control
in covet 19 that vitamin d helps
regulate and keep in control and one of
the things that's gotten a lot of press
lately has been the fact that with
severe cover 19 you get thrombolytic
events you get blood clots that do a lot
of damage in fact most of the damage
from severe covet 19
is
not just damage in the lungs but also
you get damage in the various other
organs because of blood clots and those
blood clots aren't formed by the virus
itself they're caused by the
overreaction
to the the virus and vitamin d controls
that system and helps prevent those
blood clots
fascinating and then the number of
mechanisms that were already known
pertinent to
this particular disease i mean i'm i've
got a document i think i'm i'm running
up to nearly 10 that i know about now
there are dozens and vitamin d is well
known to
control i think now more than 20 000
genes in the body so it's it's it's one
of the most ubiquitous and uh and
important hormones of all of the
hormones i mean every hormone is
important but it's
and i think it's probably worth
clarifying that the the d3 version that
we eat is several metabolic steps away
from the active form and what we measure
when we call the active form actually
isn't the active form there's another
one another step further down so you'll
hear calcium calcified or calcidol is as
the active form but it's actually
calcitriol which is the form that's used
in cells to initiate all of the immune
responses um that that help you with
vitamin d but the mechanisms are really
well understood i've written about the
many other researchers have written
about them um and and says really
baffling to understand why people would
question given the level of evidence
coming i mean the triangulation
you can get if you look at this from all
the different angles from biological
plausibility from uh
temporal
the all of the geographic data around
the world ecological studies
longitudinal studies
you know there's four decades of
research behind vitamin d that's just
being ignored
um and part of it's snobbery because
it's food science you know there's a
historic
uh weight around vitamin d's leg part of
it is i think
i mean the the literature's littered
with statistical mistakes and bad
analyses and things like that which
don't help but if you
have a good grounding in stats and
understand numbers and data it's pretty
easy to clear the fog away and see that
see the real picture that's there well i
do think that we can
excuse a lot of the doctors
who are not on board with vitamin d
because they don't have the time most of
them to dig into the
the basic literature themselves they
rely upon their medical societies and
and the the various guidelines you know
up to date and the various guidelines in
order to get their information
and
uh about 10 years ago or so
uh the vitamin d
clarion call was very loud and this the
time when my friend in alaska was
testing every single patient for vitamin
d
and uh vitamin d
uh testing at that time was covered by
medicare and groups like that
but what happened is after that they did
these population studies
in which they used the us rda as the
amount of vitamin d they were going to
supplement with they were very poorly
designed studies with a very
uh
primitive understanding or not a very
adequate understanding of how vitamin d
works and so they supplemented people
with way less vitamin d than they should
have
they supplemented them for a shorter
amount of time than they should have and
they
supplemented people who were already
vitamin d sufficient as well as people
who were deficient and so that would
dilute the uh results and so it'd be a
little bit like i the example i give is
um we all know that amoxicillin uh is
extremely effective against strep coat
to this day we don't have severe
resistance for amoxicillin against strep
thread that's what everybody uses 500
milligrams three times a day is the
accepted dose if we instead
gave people in a study five milligrams
of amoxicillin three times a day and
then had another group which we didn't
give any amoxicillin at all we could
easily prove that amoxicillin is not
useful at all for strep throat and so
they basically disproved vitamin d being
useful with studies that inadequately
dosed people and were poorly designed
and those studies were very widely
accepted and as a result
the
physicians were given the message oh
this vitamin d thing looked good
but we've disproven it it's really a
bunch of nothing and so a lot of the uh
physicians now when they hear about
vitamin d they say i'll fool me once
you're not going to fool me twice i know
this vitamin d thing is just a few
zealots it doesn't really work
and
martinu did a study in 2017 that's
probably the most widely cited study for
vitamin d in which what he did was he
took all the studies
that had been poorly designed
from uh
vitamin d
uh
going back and did a meta-analysis in
which he looked at individual patient
data
it was a massive study and showed with
this meta-analysis data that oh but if
you use high enough doses and you don't
give the boluses but rather you give it
daily or weekly you do get a dramatic
effect on uh respiratory viruses in fact
respiratory viruses in the elderly are
cut in half influenza rates
death rates could be cut in half with
vitamin d supplementation and that did
get some attention
so uh
that study to me the big takeaway on it
is you have to look at the studies and
see whether or not they were designed
appropriately to get meaningful results
right or
as we've seen in some of the coveted
literature
there is a
a go-to move if you want to avoid the
impression that something works the
underpowered study and so i don't know
in the case that you cite whether or not
treating with uh
such a meager dose of vitamin d in a
population that may already be
sufficient was
intentional sabotage or simply an
accident but the fact is it is all too
possible
to generate the impression that
something highly effective isn't
effective at all if you design the study
in such a way that it doesn't reveal the
effect
that's right
so underpowered studies looking at the
evidence i mean i've noticed this
phenomenon over and over again people
will and in fact nice did this when they
looked at
they first did their review which you
know at the time i think i counted 8 000
results on google scholar for vitamin d
and coronavirus and then they came out
with a review that looked at five
studies they actually did put our paper
in an appendix of studies that they
wouldn't consider because it was a
pre-print um although martino then
applied for some grant funding using it
so it was good enough for him to apply
for money uh but not good enough to tell
the world that you know vitamin d was a
thing to do um but
the
if if you i use a metaphor which is if
you have
detectives you've got some good
detectives and some bad detectives and
you tell them to investigate a murder
and five of them go to the house and see
the murder weapon and those to find the
blood and the victim and the other five
go down to the pub or look in their
kitchen or in their own you know their
own or have a beer or whatever they're
going to come back with different
reports some are because of incompetence
and laziness
and some might be just corrupt
you can't take
five studies that show strong evidence
and then five studies that didn't
provide evidence and somehow say there's
no evidence studies cancel out the
positive evidence from the first five
but very often in the literature and i
think this is true in medicine in
general
studies that report ever no evidence of
effect are immediately interpreted as
evidence of no effect which is a
completely different statement and you
need you can
make a study that can prove there's no
effect within a certain tolerance but
you have to have incredibly high power
i'm not aware of any study that's done
that
the hasty biobank study claimed to have
done it but that was statistical fiction
linda and i collaborated with the
physicists to take down that paper and
point out that they've they've just
artificially inflated they had about a
thousand data points and they they
claimed it they had nearly half a
million by mislabeling all of
i've never read a worse piece of science
in my life i don't know how that got
published
um it just shows how broken peer review
is and the number of studies that quote
that study the reason we went to the
trouble of rebutting it uh formally was
because people were still quoting it a
year later and it's it's
blatantly wrong and i don't understand
how anyone could read it and take it
seriously but it's it's taken seriously
all the time
yeah we we see this pattern uh across
the covid literature
and
um
it's very well let's put it this way you
know the story is well we don't have
enough evidence that
vitamin d or ivermectin
uh works and therefore we're advising
caution because of the danger of using
it well what if there is no danger
because these things are comparatively
safe well there is a danger and then you
look into the evidence of that and it
isn't really evidence but then
you see something like flavoxamine right
which has now been demonstrated to be
highly effective against covet and
there's no move uh
evident to make it the standard of care
so the point is well
it seems like actually you don't want
things that work to be used because and
you're just using the fact that you
don't think the evidence is good enough
to explain why you're not using these
things and the way we can tell is that
when you have something that does meet
your standard of evidence you still
don't use it right so
sometimes the sometimes the politics get
in the way and the politics are just
unbelievable if you look at what's
happened with monoclonal antibodies in
the united states monoclonal antibodies
have been around and have been had
emergency use use authorization they're
very expensive but they didn't work
since january
of 2021 but very few states were using
them and they weren't very well
publicized well the governors of texas
and florida
you know the two states that are
flouting a lot of the uh
uh restriction lockdown kind of things
both highly endorsed monoclonal
antibodies and started opening up
monoclonal antibodies centers so that
anybody who wanted them could easily
access monoclonal antibodies so what
happens next
monoclonal antibodies
are suddenly um
regulated the distribution becomes
regulated by the federal government and
they start
and they forbid the companies from
shipping to florida or texas because
they say we need to distribute these
equitably across all the states so these
states that aren't interested in
monoclonal antibodies have stockpiles of
them while
texas and florida are shorted which even
if they were to distribute those and use
them this will prevent you from
accumulating the evidence that they work
right if texas and florida start
allowing anybody who wants monoclonal
antibodies to use them
and they suddenly have low rates of
covered harm from people who have been
infected then that would raise the
question of whether the rest of the
state should get on board on the other
hand if you distribute these things in
such a way that the effect is diluted
and nobody has a very strong effect
because they're so widely distributed
you won't see that pattern and you can
uh dismiss dismiss this potentially
important
curative agent uh and you know basically
rationalize your failure to use it yeah
and the whole thing is is you've got
something that's very
strongly preventative
for severe copa 19 hospitalizations and
death whether it's vitamin d ivermectin
monoclonal antibodies whatever then you
lose the rationale for emergency use
authorization for the vaccines the
vaccines seem to be the emergency right
and so we have this one therapy which
clearly the public health authority has
uh signed up for and uh will entertain
no evidence that it was an error
um
and we have all sorts of other things on
the table from slovoxamine to vitamin d
uh to monoclonal antibodies which are
you know
just unable to get a proper
hearing
[Music]